my next guest is an American Muslim
doctor she says congresswoman Omar is an
embarrassment and a disgrace to the
Muslim community joining me now is dr.
kanta Achmed a member of the Council on
Foreign Relations and a counselor at the
USC Shoah foundation dr. you also say
that Omar is not the victim she portrays
herself to be great to have you on why
is that it it's just diabolical that she
commits yet another violence against the
families of survivors of 9/11 and the
families of victims of 9/11 for more
foremost I'm a physician who takes care
of people that have survived or had
diseases complicated by the World Trade
Center attacks that was devastating
remarks that I actually heard while I
was in Africa in Rwanda commemorating a
genocide there she is
depicting in this diminishment what I
would describe as a profound denial of
9/11 and as you know I work a lot with
anti-semitism and it reminds me of the
mentality of Holocaust deniers or as
we've seen in Rwanda there are some who
would deny the genocide there too so
this denial raises in me a couple of
questions does she really think 9/11 was
not an Islamist jihadist attack which
came from within the Muslim fold the
Koran tells us Islam tells us we must be
strict in observing justice even if it
means means bearing witness against
ourselves against our kith and our kin
and it also tells us we have to do that
with impartiality
we cannot be biased if we have certain
prejudices she harbors prejudices she
diminished the worst attack on this
country since Pearl Harbor and she does
an assault on my patience on all
families were grieving for their
survivors it's despicable worse is that
opponents whether in her party or not
are shielding her from the kind of
searing criticism she deserves
well dr. Ahmed we're gonna have an
entire hour on just this conversation of
Islam in the world today especially its
role in America and this conversation
should focus on the facts you just laid
out a whole bunch of them we really
appreciate
you're being with us tonight thank you
so much thank you Laura and if I can
just say this observation of denying 911
was made to me when we discussed this in
Rwanda with Muslims with African Muslims
we're going to keep this conversation
going but we appreciate your joining us